depuis le début de la pandémie le québec
dénombre 147 décès liés à la coved par
cent mille habitants ça c'est deux fois
le taux enregistré en ontario mais selon
françois legault ça ne veut pas dire que
la coved fait plus de décès au québec
qu'ailleurs les chiffres de surmortalité
parce que ce sont les chiffres qui sont
les plus importants quand on regarde les
chiffres sont disponibles pour toutes
les provinces puis les états unis
jusqu'en septembre 2021 on voit que
toutes proportions gardées il ya moins
de décès au québec en ontario que dans
le reste du canada qu'aux états unis la
surmortalité c'est un vieil outils
qu'utilisent les démographes pour
mesurer l'impact d'une catastrophe comme
une grosse vague de chaleur ou encore
une pandémie
normalement
survenait
mise à part la vague de décès dans les
ch et celle des la cour de la
surmortalité au québec ressemble en
effet à celle observée dans le reste du
canada la surmortalité québécoise est
également inférieure à celle observée
dans le nord-est des etats-unis par
exemple pour les 18 premiers mois de la
pandémie la surmortalité et de 3,7 pour
cent au québec la proportion s'élève à 4
7% dans le reste du canada et à 16 8%
aux etats-unis si on utilise la
surmortalité comme indicateur c'est que
d'un endroit à l'autre la façon de
déclarer un décès lié à la coved varie
beaucoup par exemple une personne qui
était en lice
par exemple
dans ce cas ci on va identifier le
cancer comme cause initiale de décès
mais la copie comme causes secondaires
mais on va leur apporter comme comme
dessert ou la commune est appliquée et
c'est la bonne façon de faire
si le québec utilisent les normes de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ce
n'est pas le cas ailleurs au pays la
docteure tard à moriarty de l'université
de toronto met d'ailleurs en garde le
gouvernement ontarien et les autres
provinces en affirmant que les données
fournies par le québec reflète
probablement ce qui se passe
partout au pays et que le nombre de
décès dans le reste du canada est en
réalité bien plus élevé que ce que
montrent les données officielles
très bientôt les autres provinces
canadiennes selon ces projections vont
se retrouver dans la même situation que
que le québec mais on ne peut pas
vraiment dire que le québec fait pire ou
mieux que les autres ce qui est juste
c'est que le québec calcul mieux et plus
rapidement les décès liés à la coved ici
vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal